joining us now the author of the number
one bestseller the Russian hoax the
illicit scheme to clear Hillary Clinton
and Priam Donald Trump Gregg Jarrett
along with investigative reporter Fox
News contributor Sarah Carter Sarah we
begin with you John Solomon's report
from tonight this is now concrete
evidence the FBI was told everything
about Christopher Steele who paid for
the the Russian dirt dossier lies and
they then used it anyway to spy in spite
of what James Comey says well it was to
spy and what's worse Sean is the fact
that the FBI was well aware what
Christopher Steele was up to what he was
doing the fact that Christopher Steele
himself had admitted to Cadillac the
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State at
the time that he was in a release this
information before the election this was
certainly to target then candidate Trump
and eventually President Trump because
remember after they get the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance warrant to spy
on Carter page which they did not
disclose to the courts all the
information that they had and where this
information came from and the fact that
half of it was lies they continued to
spy on Carter page renewing it for four
times during 2016 and throughout 2017
all the way until the fall the last one
actually being signed by Rudd Rosenstein
so what John broke here is so
significant and so important it's going
to unleash the Avalanche because now
they're going to have to explain why
they did this and it is absolutely
spying when you concoct a tale to
actually look into other people's emails
listen into their telephone
conversations and try to set up a duly
elected President of the United States
the avalanche that I keep saying coming
cascading down Greg Jarrett this is but
a small part we have of course the
inspector general's report on FISA abuse
we have now the Attorney General that
will look into Hillary's written
investigation we'll have the Hoover
report on leaked materials we will have
302s we will have gang of eight we will
have the five
applications themselves Muller's dead
whether people can face the truth or not
now act to the curtain is up and John's
documentary evidence now proves
conclusively that James Comey was lying
to a FISA Court and of course tonight on
CNN you played the clip when he said and
he went by the book that's also a lie to
the American public you know James Comey
is now swinging these wild haymakers
because he knows that very soon he's
going he's going down on the canvas for
a ten count he is in deep serious legal
jeopardy
none of the things lying to a FISA Court
making government documents that he
stole starting an investigation without
credible evidence spying on the Trump
campaign and making false statements to
Congress I hope he saved all of the
money he made from that phony book of
his talking about liars and lying lying
people because he's going to need the
money for his defense team Gregg Jarrett
remind me to never piss you off because
that was a pretty damning indictment
that's why you had the number one
bestseller in the country for weeks all
right thank you both great work both of
you